now welcome to this video playing
tactical cm I'm going to master my
vision yeah let's see what I can do it
or not one of the most comfortable
opponents for me I've got a pretty bad
score 3 out of 10 so playing the
classical line here of the NIMS Oh with
90 f 3 ok so I'm going to prepare for a
bishop recapture this is a bit
comparable to the zurich variation ok
this one ok let's go away three now this
this looks actually quite comfortable
for white I think not sure that I'm
really threatening a discovery here but
there the idea is that hmm ha Bishop g5
but it looks a bit uncomfortable Bishop
g5 okay let's do that I'm not sure that
he can so easily break the pin now
long-term this can be awkward this pin
is Bishop is a bit away they're on a
five sometimes g5 is possible
yeah not quite Sean my idea is just III
okay so I think I'm probably I am maybe
that's an ID I am if he take Bishop the
aid yeah but ok it's not I don't have a
huge choice than anyway nope takes with
the Queen yeah II for was also possible
maybe but just eat III as good this pin
is still is still on and I mean whatever
is doing like 97 also is a is a
concession
there's also this issue of the bishop on
a five if I get in but should be 21
castles hmm that's interesting that's
interesting I cannot ship t3 and that
looks that looks like a very very fishy
move a very fishy move Bishop d3 Bishop
e7 isn't there something that I can do
that with their with this weekend
diagonal
I don't see it Bishop takes Queen takes
Queen II for bishops III yeah I can move
the king then and that might be good but
I don't trust it yeah c'mon let's let's
play play a simple move maybe I am I
lost part of my advantage hammer so it's
possible some Queen Queen takes or
beatings okay let's keep it simple check
with the Queen
yeah okay so I maybe I had something
flossing that I missed but this is
definitely a good position for wide so i
shouldn't be too critical them okay
let's see how I play it be five this
Bishop f5 maybe b4 b5 it's not not quite
clear because I'm i would have an
advantage in many ways so his problem is
that his knights are really bad they are
totally limited in scope by the bishop
pal I can just push the point of the
board
now g5 interesting maybe a FOIA to
prevent that slightly debatable
therefore is good in any case but I
wanted to go provencher five
look the eight maybe so going for work
28 maybe okay
just offering this end game if he is
avoiding it he gives me the D file for
the Queen yeah or this this one which is
also a queen trade under a little bit
more favorable circumstances in
comparison okay so um just trading and
Bishop Bishop they are probably
ideas to get in this Bishop b8 idea so
um have to have to use the King somehow
okay 98 I overlooked that idea that's
too buddy that is a stupid mistake to
make on my part f5 before maybe I'll
shoot yeah that's not what I wanted
ready d 5 f 44 and he has got it blocked
and stupid I was badly played by me Oh
what time morning that's I don't think
that's good really that's too ambitious
Jeff no it's no check you cannot check
the porn there check check yeah I don't
know can I somehow play for win in this
position queen sorry King here check
going up up here is f six then I came
out too late Jeff yeah I don't think I
can I can win of course I should have
won the game because the endgame here
with the two bishops this is just
totally totally rotten for black
computers totally under estimating the
position giving 0.2 this is almost to
win i think if why this white is playing
it right so what should I have done I
mean I didn't see the idea that he gets
the night to e8 otherwise this is
attractive you are getting the bishop
over there to have this idea but that
means that i should i should improve
from him how would do i do that a five
or something to get in f3 bishop you
want a five this kind of idea yeah okay
maybe I yes he has ideas for fortresses
yeah okay this is true he has ideas for
fortresses he has he keeps the night on
d 7
and plays and I know night kini
seven-night f6e a d6 and like f6 and
stays yeah maybe this is the way to do
it just just stay totally passive with
black and set up a poor fortress that
that's probably probably true that's
probably true I wonder I wonder if I
miss something probably I did Queenie
five wins because we should be too comes
okay winning a piece let's a frustrating
okay yeah I wasn't really looking very
hard because I thought this is just just
great yeah this end game it is nice but
it's not as good as a thorium I was too
optimistic them okay what what about
this situation ub6 it looked really
weird but the computer doesn't see and
see any refutation down I mean this is
this is also also really just good yeah
this is this is really strong yeah he
has nothing against this and they're
picking up the piece quite quite quite
ugly for black it's a complete piece you
can take and then test to do something
crazy to just continue the game okay
well thanks for watching